[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome to another episode of what's up
Prof hello Walter I'm Martin we have to
discuss a few things today but before we
do that
we want to just talk a little bit about
the year that's gone
yes it's been a very amazing year and
many things have happened
and if we look at the prophetic picture
and its implementation and you think
back over the year
the preparations that happened in the
last year in terms of the medical field
and the implementation of rules and
regulations when we look at what
happened in
the environmental sphere the role of the
papacy allowed out to see the letter cop
27 the new Commandments I mean the list
is is really quite extraordinary it is
even at a wall that started in February
I think that was a good distraction
to get all the other things into place
as well
so Martin things are happening and there
are so many things happening that you
can easily lose focus that's true
because you can be busy with this fire
or with that fire or with this ideology
or that ideology and then you have of
course the social uh catastrophe that we
have and the various viewpoints of
liberalism versus conservatism and all
of these thrown into the mix you know it
makes for a super blend yeah and like
one of those episodes that we had on
sobox teachings you can easily become
distracted and make one point your
soapbox you have to step back and look
at the big picture
so Martin we've had a very busy year
it's been a very exhausting year
and in many ways I will be grateful when
I see the back of this year
but I do not have great help for a
better one to come
let's just take a breath and a breather
and see if we can face the next one when
it comes with renewed energies and that
brings us to gratefulness towards our
viewers and our supporters and
without them it wouldn't have been
possible nothing would be possible to do
any of these this work and we want to
thank them from the bottom of our hearts
for all of it yes and thank you for
keeping it rolling you know all those
comments and things people write and
people have so many questions and many
times within the questions people answer
and that helps us we get so many
thousands of questions it's impossible
for us to handle it all and some people
get frustrated if they don't jump
immediately
but uh thank you for all that help as
well it's really is a great contribution
keep the discussion going yeah and maybe
just a reminder that
the distribution of our material
of these videos that we make it we
cannot do it alone no need your help
just distribute share and all of that on
digital media and even hard copies and
now everything is in place all of those
promises that we made of free
distribution that has been set up now
the stocks have been ordered everything
is there so North America will be
supplied and very soon the continent of
Europe will be supplied and that would
be impossible without viewer assistance
so
wow what can we say thank you thank you
very much yeah so there is an
introduction video on the distribution
center of North America and I'll put a
link in the description of this video
and you can go and watch that video to
find out more of how to get in contact
and all of those things that you need to
get this message out and then we've got
other ideas and we want to get more
involved in the health message uh doing
what you know what the gospel tells us
to do take care of people's physical
needs so that you can take care of the
spiritual needs and all of these things
there are so many things in the pipeline
and we have to dream big
and walk by the power of God in as far
as he permits us to do so it's the only
way so thank you let's get on with this
discussion I'll open with a word of pray
and then we can dive into it okay let's
do that
our heavenly father
we thank you above all
for the privilege of doing this work
work for you
now Lord we ask again that you please
bless our discussion Enlighten our minds
and let your words speak through Us in
Jesus name amen amen
Martin we're talking about Ascension of
the Catholic church and the rise of
Christian nationalism
and we have spoken about it on a number
of occasions shown a number of things
but this ball is beginning to roll
it's like a snowball it's like it's all
small but as it rolls on it becomes a
big and we said many times that we
believe that there will be a pendulum
swing
because King of the North King of the
South ideologies will Clash even though
they sit at the same table yes and
eventually the King of the North
ideology which must entail Christian
nationalism
must gain the ascendancy so an Ascension
to the United Nations seems like a good
idea but in order to get impetus behind
it you need the chaos
and so we've had a lot of Chaos in the
world
we've had chaos in terms of the health
issues we've had chaos in terms of the
climate issues and then of course there
must be economic chaos as well and so
let's see if there's any preparation for
this economic chaos
and we've been warned that the world is
heading towards a recession
there's a great energy crisis because of
the war in Ukraine the Martin nothing
happens in politics that hasn't been
planned no I mean just you you just
mentioned now because of the war yes but
like we showed in the previous video
or two videos ago
there's a transition period and that
will be accompanied by pain they've
warned us they've warned us and Klaus
Schwab has made it quite clear he's an
interesting character by the way and
let's not say too much less we get
censored
yes so Martin all of these things are
happening and always there's been
preparation
you know when it came to the health
issues there were practice runs and we
showed those in previous programs so
there was a long build up towards this
final
cataclysm that we had in the last few
years
when it comes to the environmental
crisis they had cartoons on for the
children yeah in the 90s in the 90s
already where there was planets Captain
Planet and it's interesting how
everybody was on board you know it was
Every Nation tribe and people was
involved in this great battle and this
led up to cop 27.
or where all of these things are being
implemented and then you have the
spiritual aspects coming out of the pen
or the Vatican those Jesuit writers are
very busy and we think it's Pope Francis
putting this thing together under a very
special uh spiritual guidance which I
believe is Serpentine
but let's leave it at that so we're
going to talk about some of these issues
let's have a look at the impending
economic crisis
here is ABC News November 16 2022
so these tech companies have imposed
major layoffs in 2022.
meta cut about 11 000 employees
meta CEO Mark Zuckerberg last week
announced that the company would be
laying off about 11
000 employees an estimated 13 percent of
its Workforce
but interesting Martin
haven't these companies all had record
earnings that's exactly so their coffers
are full
their coffers are overflowing and yet
they're laying of all of these people do
they know something
I am sure there's something Brewing
Twitter cut about
3700 employees
and uh of course there's an ideological
battle raging in in that one the King of
the North and the King of the South seem
very engaged
when it comes to Twitter
and then Amazon cut about 10 000
employees didn't they also have record
earnings yeah all of these came into the
pandemic already
making record profits then the pandemic
shot it up even more now they are
blaming this apparently on after the
pandemic now it's slowed down oh I see
then other companies like lift and
stripe they also are cutting employees
Redfin cut almost a thousand Microsoft
cut a thousand Robinhood cut 23 percent
of its employees coinbase cut 1100
employees Martin
are they preparing for something and
they want to keep their coffers intact I
think if you want to exactly what you're
saying if you want to keep your profit
margin on the same level and you know
something's coming get rid of them maybe
excess Personnel but don't think that
the person Personnel that's left are not
going to be doing do the work because
the work won't get less they'll do
exactly the same things they're trying
to hedge themselves
I think so too
all right here's another interesting one
it's also from the 22nd of November
Google's parent company alphabet to lay
off 10 000 employees
Google's parent company is reportedly
gearing up delay of about ten thousand
poor performing employees
button who employs ten thousand poor
performing employees I don't buy that
one do you buy that one
either they're very poor employers
yeah or they're looking for an excuse
that's a thing
or six percent of its Workforce in the
big Tech layoff season kicked off by
meta Amazon Twitter Salesforce and more
met the rough Global conditions
interesting that all of these companies
are making mega mega profits and yet
they are doing this yeah we're not
talking about Millions we're talking
about billions in clean profit yes
so imagine the world is heading
somewhere we don't have to go into
details just take note we are supposed
to be observers right that's the thing
not to start picketing but just to
observe just to see what is happening
and by the way just a question all of
these companies that we have listed here
didn't their CEOs all visit the Vatican
all of them and just after
musk visited he bought Twitter just
after he bought Twitter he started
laying off just after after he started
laying off the rest of them started
laying off it's maybe coincidence
something interesting or maybe Martin
poor performing
means the wrong ideology
that can be true as well could it be
yeah could it be that there must come as
streamlining so that we have everybody
coming in line with a particular
ideology the mindset must come right
okay so before when there was conflict
north south
then you wanted both sides there now you
want a little bit of a clean up to get
rid of the so-called poor performing yes
but the poor performing as we said is
really an indictment to those who
employed them
that's true aren't they supposed to vet
these things beforehand and why at once
in one shot
yes and all of these thousands and
thousands of people I wonder what would
happen if CNN wanted to change its
ideology how many poor performing people
would they have to fire yeah probably
also well didn't they go through a
similar thing or I mean if you
understand from right to left Fox would
have to do it if you change from left to
right then CNN would have to do it this
is always the Galleon dialectic two
opposing ideologies so now the pendulum
starting to swing get rid of the mindset
that's not relevant to the time is it
possible just a thought just a thought
and now let's have a look at the rise of
the papacy because remember all of these
CEOs
Yep they're not being laid off
no no
they all went to the Vatican
and they must have particular marching
orders right
now the vatican's clout they've always
been working behind the scenes that's
just how Jesuits work right they work
behind the scenes but actually they
wield the power
so now they are taking a more direct
approach if the time has come for the
kings of the world to give their power
unto the Beast
we will give you the direction but
because of your ideologies you never
wanted to implement our stand
you wanted to have your secular stand
but I am the king of the north and I
will curtail your secular stand and I
will make sure you implement my moral
statutes because I am the Antichrist and
I want to get rid of God's statutes
that's the thinking that's going on
there that's in their minds yes right
because they've been enemies of God from
the beginning and a leopard doesn't
change its spots and the sick thing
about it is that they doing it with a
Christian God for God apparently and
I've got all these Christians on board
with a false ideology
namely futurism which comes out of the
pen of the Jesuits
it's sad that protestantism should be so
duped as to embrace an enemy
well modern earthbeat tells us that the
papacy is no longer just an observer
the Vatican looks to wield new status in
U.N climate talks but in that new status
is just for public consumption it's
always been there
but behind the scenes now it's moving
into the fall
and if you look on the picture there
where is he speaking he's speaking in
his nuclear bunker
that is like a serpent and he's speaking
from the mouth of the serpent so he's
the spokesperson for the serpent that
gave him his power and great Authority
the typology of him standing there in
that place and speaking is amazing if
you take it in biblical
language and and why would you design a
building to be like a serpent and he
speaks between the fangs
when Cardinal Pietro parolin addressed
world leaders in the first days of cop
27 the United Nations climate change
Summit held in charm al-shike Egypt he
did so on equal footing with the heads
of state assembled before him that's
also a ruse
because the spiritual sword is over the
secular sword
and very true the speech marked the
first of the Holy See as a formal
partner of the UN framework convention
on climate change
Vatican officials have signaled that the
move is more than symbolic and reflects
the church's intention to play a more
active role in the often tense and
turbulent climate negotiations that have
played out for more than a quarter
Century to varying degrees of progress
and setbacks
Martin not just symbolic
and the taking an act of role they've
always had an active role they're just
moving on to the stage rather than being
the Puppet Masters behind the stage and
I think it's actually more biblical than
symbolic
and the vatican's Ascension the word
alone tells you a lot of things
from Observer status to full participant
offers a new Reason for Hope
we now are at the same pedestal with the
rest of the negotiators he said on
symbolism alone the vatican's new status
is significant
moving from symbolism to substance
mutton does that sound biblical to you
I'm telling you huh you cannot get it
more biblical than that and for them to
actually engage authentically as
negotiators and see how they can change
the culture within the UN framework
convention on climate change
they've run the philosophy of the UN
from the beginning
their Jesuit plant over there from whom
they distance themselves
but actually embrace you see but the
problem was if this had happened before
people would have there would have been
a buzz because they wouldn't have wanted
them there but now they they're actually
long for them there because they are
wondering thinking admiring exactly the
Beast
this will help the church speak with one
unified voice who's the church there
Martin the Catholic church or all of
them
well it's the it's all churches but the
mother leading them so
herodias is telling Salome what to do
and she really wants the head of John
the Baptist
unified voice at the international level
and to promote not only best practices
that sounds like common good to me even
more importantly the more robust ethical
model and spiritual framework isn't that
what we are supposed to be aware of
it's a pretty bold move because it also
is a stepping stone up in political
space and into a diplomacy role where
for now the Vatican has been playing
more but just moral role holding the
principles and the values but not
pushing it into commitment
London they are speaking with the tongue
of a serpent
and you know because they're political
representatives were placed there by
them yes
so they just used another mouthpiece a
front is this the wound healing
completely that's why they have the
arrogance to call it an Ascension nobody
else gets that title
nobody else ascended to the United
Nations except them right
isn't Ascension hasn't it got something
to do with a king well what happened to
Nebuchadnezzar
remember the dispute about Daniel being
in the third year and the king in the
second year how does this work
you see they use different forms of
Reckoning in case of Nebuchadnezzar they
had an Ascension year and then the first
year the second year yeah so the
Ascension year is the year when he took
the throne so if you take it here this
is the year that they took take the
throne and from here on they'll be
ruling they will rule he they will be
the rulers of Babylon doesn't it stand
on their forehead yeah Babylon the
mother of harlots and all the other
churches
all together well we saw that on Mount
Sinai didn't we that's it
so this is a historic moment it's a
historic moment for the Human family and
it should signal that glimmer of hope
now munene said
Martin
I think it does give me hope because it
means that the Sharad will come to an
end soon
the light that we are seeing at the end
of the tunnel is not a train that is
coming to run over us it's actually the
Sun
the Divine sun shining upon us and
brother son now is Illuminating our
heart and we can be hopeful again
Martin power unto the Beast
and this munene is the spokesperson of
the Vatican at the United Nations and
this was his official speech
referring to brother son is the man
insane
unfortunately if you speak with the
tongue of the serpent this is what will
come out so insanity is The New Normal
may God help us
fortunately I have a different view on
the light of the at the end of the
tunnel I also see a light but I see that
it is it is the train that is going to
end the system because when the stone
strikes the feet
how much is left over nothing nothing
it's ground to powder and the powder is
taken away there will be not a Vestige
of this system left
there was a time in world's history
when people could rely on governments to
help you and bail you out and be your
protector and maybe even your friend
those days are over we have
dictatorships masquerading as democracy
that's just at the moment tyrannical
rule is implemented
now this is an interesting one it comes
from Global citizen forum
this is quite a substantial Forum with a
lot of clout they've been running for
quite a few years I mean if you remember
every year they've got a huge concert
sometimes different places all over the
world with all the big names coming
together I mean the 24th of September
they had a big concert where Mariah
Carey and Metallica and all these people
were singing well all those rock bands
of the past were all Jesuit puppies in
any case
if we can imagine a better world we can
build one but only by engaging with and
developing our inner selves can we
change the world so we must first change
ourselves
button this hope that Humanity has of
changing the inner self is a vain hope
because without God it is impossible
right without Christ Living in you
that's he's the only one that can help
you change yourself so which forces that
living in them I think the force is
called Legion
with delegates hailing from more than 30
countries every aspect of the summit has
been intentionally designed to support
attendees embark on a personal journey
of self-discovery and evolution keep an
open mind let yourself go and try not to
judge that sounds Serpentine to me
doesn't it sound like that to you very
new age definitely there's no doubt
about that a common theme throughout the
day was the renewed focus on the
importance of inner connection
with the pursuit of global progression
stemming from the combined action of its
8 billion individuals Martin I refuse to
be part of that crowd yeah the problem
is you've got now two streams going out
you've got this stream the global
Citizen and then you've got the
nationalism stream
but we don't want to be a part of either
doesn't didn't wasn't it Gandhi I think
who said that even one is a majority if
it is the truth
let alone 8 billion
so sayoon and Alexander mandulek hosted
a Transcendent sound healing session to
awaken our Collective Consciousness and
activate our Highest Potential whilst
Deepak Chopra led a Beachside meditation
session providing new perspective on
human metamorphosis and guiding the
audience through an internal supercharge
and Revival I'm so glad I wasn't part of
that this is the type of thing that's
happening all over the world now when
you look at Babylon
it has three components right yeah we we
we're sick and tired of the Beast
already he's everywhere and he's now
ascended
and then you have the false prophet but
you also have the dragon yeah and this
ideology is part of the dragon and don't
tell me that Dragon philosophy hasn't
infiltrated the churches don't we have
meditation and yoga and lectio Divina
and rituals and Magic circles and
labyrinths yes breath prayers and all
this nonsense visualizations the
meditation not the biblical one there's
uh senses meditation on the Bible the
nazian spirituality it's all and
everything is Christian these days yeah
spiritual formation it's all satanic
there is no such thing
as good spiritual formation it's demonic
it comes from Jesuit philosophy biblical
meditation is meditating on the word its
meaning internalizing it and applying it
to your life and that's it it's so an A
in plain words it's thinking about what
you've read
remembering that not sitting and
asking God to Enlighten you as to the
deeper type of logical meanings of many
of the stories
so this human metamorphosis Journey
unveils New Era of globe and citizenship
concludes with their VR project
Chopra verse which is said to bring
well-being into the metaverse modern
this new terminology that they are using
and the companies that have been created
meta
they all tell us that all of these are
interconnected in a very intricate way
the session journey into the metaverse
invited individuals to embrace what it
means to be a meta human
a state which Deepak Chopra describes as
a shared vision and diversity to reach
emergence to birth a new reality filled
with wonder creativity and joy a social
transformation this sounds like Alize
Bailey exactly the same it's exactly the
same this is so new age this is that
euphoria that you're going to live in
but it's not reality it's virtual
reality yes now Satan turns it Round And
he says you are living in a matrix you
are living in a make-believe world where
you are actually a puppet being
controlled by a puppeteer but this is in
my opinion nothing short of demonic
position it is and that's where it's
leading because what adds on to all of
this
you've got spiritual formation you've
got all this
virtual
let's say deception that can happen yes
so who knows what we'll see by means of
holograms or whatever
so for that you of course need a lot of
new technology Now isn't it interesting
that according to Tech juice the new
technology has arrived that allows us to
speak to our dead relatives
so they create a situation where you
actually communicate with your dead
relative
now it's still electronic but if you
really believe that you are speaking to
a dead relative then you might as well
be visiting the witch of Endor yeah
especially when you don't have a true
biblical understanding of the state of
the dead so how important is the
doctrine of the mortality of the Soul
as opposed to the papal doctrine of the
immortality of the Soul I think it's
going to play one of the pivotal roles
in the time that we're going in okay so
by these two Sunday sacredness and the
immortality of the Soul he will sweep
the whole of humanity into his camp
how important is it that we understand
the doctrine of mortality
it will be a life and death
understanding okay now when you take
Hollywood
when you take any one of these
organizations any media whatsoever what
side of the equation are they on or the
papal side or on the biblical side on
the papal site immortality of the soul
and is it just the Seventh-Day
Adventists that understand it or did the
reformers already understand Martin
Luther did Martin Luther understand it
did uh Tyndall understand it did fitzger
understand it did the early reformers
understand it why don't they understand
it anymore because the Jesuit came in
aha
so these people are saying isn't that
exciting that now we can talk to our
dead ones yes why not new technology has
arrived enabling us to speak to your
loved ones who are dead now
you can live with your dead ones live
inside your smartphones as voice
assistants
so you can get them to be your voice
assistant
the app is created by the
california-based company here after AI
the company aims to enable communication
between the living and the dead mutton
it sounds like Halloween come to life
[Laughter]
well if you think it's it's a you can
always take all of this and try and
justify it and say yeah but it's not
really the same thing if you just start
to gamble here in this
what's to say you say for instance you
do understand the two biblical
um Doctrine on the immortality of the
Soul
if you start dabbling on on this it's
like playing there where the devil is
all right but look how interconnected it
becomes
technology like this which enables
communication with the deceased has been
a decades-old Mainstay of Science
Fiction
Health Care Providers and spiritualists
for decades have always wanted to have
something like that and Martin if you
look at the health care system in the
world there are many in the health
business that are working on the
esoteric level that use the pendulum to
determine what disease you have what the
Cure is and you have to be so careful
because you could be handing yourselves
over to demonic forces
if you take the field of chanting to
enhance the force of medication for
example as opposed to the simple
Curative powers of herbs that God has
put into nature yeah you have a total
mix so is it possible for the Whole
Health Care
uh industry
to become involved in demonic activity
definitely isn't that pharmacia
witchcraft
now though it is becoming a reality and
one that is increasingly accessible
thanks to the advancement in Ai and
voice technology
now if you put this with a metaverse and
Chopra that you've just had what type of
mix do you have then you have a
catastrophic mix
so Martin
we have on the one hand this great
movement of bringing inner spirituality
into a movement
but then you also in the Bible have the
Assurance let's put it that way
that the powers that be will implement
the mark of the beast
we've spoken about it many times
so in some way or other
the pendulum must swing so that that
ideology can become a reality as well
if we can if I may put it again into the
King of the North and South
the global citizens
is actually falling under the King of
the South
and nationalism is King of the North yes
all right so here the Washington times
tells us that the ascendants of national
conservatism
is something that they are watching now
the Washington Times is probably quite
liberal
let's see what they say to the surprise
of many it turns out that the idea of a
Nation a group of families tribes and
communities with common experiences
knitted together for the common good and
motivated by a common purpose is still
very much alive
now I find it interesting that the Pope
constantly rails against nationalism but
only against Christians yeah it doesn't
rail against the nationalism of let's
say Islamic countries no Embraces
exactly not only even Embraces it he
propagates it I mean if you take how for
the Amazon people how he stands they
must be looking forward it must be
looking after their ideologies why
because their ideologies are not a
danger to his system unless you have
conquered the system then you can Ascend
and play your role so this is very
interesting so it's very much alive
intellectuals steeped in corrosive and
pointless Enlightenment ideas about the
universality of The Human Experience are
uncomfortable with nationalities
nationalism and the idea that people
identify as citizens of a Nation rather
than citizens of the world it won't
surprise anyone that those who identify
as Americans rather than Global Citizens
tilt towards the right
now we understand that the United States
will lead out when it comes to the
implementation of the mark of the beast
and it will be Protestant America that
enforces it and other nations will
follow
now when you say other nations you're
talking particularly about the Christian
nations
but in terms of certain ideologies like
climate it could be Universal
and if you have
a portion of that ideology
ensconced in the Christian Nation which
is also of a secular Nation nature like
Sunday for example then the whole world
can embrace it that's it very clever
so as part of that effort several dozen
people recently signed this statement of
principles
which is more policy than the Legacy the
Republicans have managed to enunciate in
The Last Five Years on National
conservatism site outlining their
thoughts about how best to proceed
quote we see the tradition of
independent self-governed nations as the
foundation for restoring a proper public
orientation towards patriotism courage
honor loyalty religion wisdom
congregation Family Man Woman Sabbath
and the sacred and reason and justice
it's interesting what is all in the mix
there besides all the other things like
patriotism it is religion
congregation
Sabbath yeah
reason
Justice
it sounds very jesuitical
Faith informed by reason right that's it
but or recently informed by faith which
one is it now
so the American conservative of November
2021 wrote that the only path forward is
National conservatism
Edmund Burke famously wrote in his
Reflections on the revolution in France
the age of chivalry is gone that of
sophista's economists calculators has
succeeded and the glory of Europe is
extinguished forever
it was pregnant when Burke wrote it and
an attempt to reconfigure that sentiment
for our current malaise yields something
approximating the following
the age of neutrality is gone
that of worksters oligarchs and an
arrogant ruling class has succeeded and
the glory of the post-war neoliberal
order is extinguished forever
a distinct but related formulation one
I've used before would be this President
Reagan
said that the most terrifying words are
I'm from the government and I'm here to
help
but the new most terrifying words are
I'm from the ruling class and I'm here
to subjugate you
what does this set the stage for a
pendulum swing definitely you've got
these two you see the old time the
Washington Post you've got this one type
of ideology and now you've got
it's becoming very distinct there's not
a lot of gray anymore okay so you have
to choose one of the sides that's it and
when a whole group chooses one side
what does that mean for the other side
trouble trouble don't want you so for a
long time now the King of the South has
held sway the world has become more
liberal your children are being taught
in schools that they're not boys or
girls
birth certificates are no longer signed
as male or female we have to wait for
the decision of the infant as to what
gender they are and excuse me but
idioces such as these
and people are getting fed up
now we must remember that it's easy to
become ideologically so riled up that
you jump onto a bad way it is that's the
oh that's so important that's why we
always propagate be an observer be an
observer so even if it irritates you
what is happening in the world
let's say the gender issue
or the woke issue or whatever issue it
is even if it irritates you beyond
measure always ask the question
what is the purpose what is the devil's
plan in bringing this above and he's
succeeding
because now the parents are all riled up
and they want to stop it so they want to
take the power they want to take the
power at the school board level they
want to take the power at the political
level because that's the only way you're
going to stop it so you are hurting
people into an ideological thinking
pattern
and once you have that established
anything that opposes it is the enemy
now once you've ensconced even the
Sabbath issue
and somebody opposes it
then you're against the common good then
all of a sudden the common good comes
into play even though on other aspects
you might be against it if that's it
very interesting
and then there have been books written
on the subject
and some of them quite recently and this
one is very interesting a book by
Stephen Wolfe the case for Christian
nationalism mutton
is the is the climate right for
something like that it's amazing the
timing is perfect the timing because
these two books
are now the best sellers on Amazon so
it's not some obscure little book that's
just hiding away anything that's going
on with this is now very much grabbed by
the public and here's another book
taught by an isker and it says a
Biblical guide to taking dominion and
discipling Nations
so this is Dominion of theology now we
must make it quite clear that this is
jesuitical theology that's amazing that
has been embraced by protestantism
that's how clever it is and you have to
disciple the nations in other words you
have to get the Nations to see it your
way and this is not to be confused with
the Great Commission that Christ gave no
because that has to do with eradicating
sin this has to do with dominionism
ruling and this is exactly what Christ
came
to do away with that's and they are
implementing what he has claimed as an
evil in the world now did the Jewish
Nation have dominionism definitely all
right so
was Christ for it or against it
completely again the kingdom of this
world they don't reflect the Kingdom of
Heaven in one eye out there there was
nothing he could compare it to
there was nothing in it it was going to
be swept away but this is the greatest
deception
that is coming upon the world
Christian nationalist bestseller rooted
in Folk
that's German right history Homeland
patriarchy is blood relation of a
certain 20th century German Manifesto
so here is an article that is speaking
against Christian nationalism and
they're saying you know it reminds us of
the Nazi era yeah
Christian nationalism is becoming a
bigger Factor amongst Republican voters
with 61 percent of Republican
respondents saying they supported
declaring the United States a Christian
Nation
and we showed that video some time ago
where they said when we have this
Christian Nation that we want you will
live under Christian rules that's it you
can be a Jew you can be whatever you
like but you're under Christian rules in
actual fact the guy that you're
referring to is the one that wrote the
second book that we were speaking about
very interesting
as a former Evangelical Minister I know
it is the kind of work that ends up in
the hands of Evangelical celebrities
seminarians rural pastors and Christian
influencers looking for a highbrow
theological justification
for their basis political and cultural
impulses he wolf referring to that book
takes his inspiration from both Thomas
Aquinas and the Protestant Dreadful
reformers Martin can you link Thomas of
kindness to the Protestant Reformation
no that's like trying to mix oil and
water it's impossible chalk and cheese
right forget it but this is a marriage
that Catholicism has worked very hard
for
now as far as they are concerned Thomas
the kindness is a saint as far as I'm
concerned he was demon-possessed
especially Calvin
his first major premise is that even if
Adam and Eve had not sinned humans would
have congregated in separate communities
on the planet
now it's interesting that Calvinism
has a dominionist aspect to it yes even
the early Protestants they believed in
church and state working together that's
why you have Protestant districts and
you had Catholic districts and if you
didn't fit into that ideology you better
move you have to get out we have the
same thing coming and Calvin also had
persecution and Calvin was a little bit
more radical when it came to this than
Martin Luther but even the lutherans
persecuted people when they were
ideologically different like the
anabaptists they were persecuted by
lutherans and they were persecuted by
Calvinists and they were persecuted by
Catholics I think Sabbath Keepers will
fall into that category they'll have the
Calvinists they'll have the lutherans
and they'll have the Catholics against
them and the government that's exactly
what's going to happen
Christians should thus do everything
possible to institutionalize
Christianity in their nation in order to
structure them according to God's vision
for human life
this means creating a government in
which the Civil Authorities directs its
citizens to the True Religion to the
fullest extent of their power
Wolff also advocates for the enforcement
of Sabbath laws and Punishment of false
religions I.E anything outside of the
state approved Christian practice well
he's quite right
but this is where we're heading
that's true that why is it essential for
them to enforce their ideologies I'll
tell you why Martin because they cannot
live with the other ideologies exactly
so they have to build a wall around
theirs and enforce it does that sound
like you can enforce the mark of abuse
no I think it doesn't sound like it it
will definitely be that way all right so
why do this does he throw the Sabbath
laws into his his uh documentation why
because it's important part part and
parcel of the Christian identity exactly
but whose identity is it God's all the
popes unfortunately Thomas Aquinas in
the popes uh her okay so here we go
there is no such thing
as true Christianity within this premise
because Christ
tells you that he gives you freedom of
choice this takes it away you know what
and the problem is
if I just take our own country our own
Christian people in our country how many
of them will go along with something
like this they will rejoice exactly
every Christian pastor and politician
who has readily accepted the Christian
nationalist label should be asked if
they are on board with Sabbath laws
the negation of women's suffrage and
elimination of the Constitution that
anchors our democracy if nothing else
the work provides a litmus test for what
Christian nationalism actually means in
the public square and a chance to
realize the tragic consequences it may
have for our country now there are still
people that are awake like the author
here Bradley or Nishi but the problem is
is a minority no he's right he's
propagating all the other stuff again
on the other side
you see those two streams
you've got the King of the South mindset
and this person is falling into that one
he wants all the liberal stuff to be
we have a choice but we know from the
Bible that the King of the North
ideology will be the final one
so let's have a look at this interview
where the author wolf gives some of his
ideas he's very careful as to how he
says things
but nevertheless he sticks to his point
if someone accused me of a Christian
being a Christian ass like yeah I mean
yeah I am
um and I hope that the term can be a
rallying point for people to say no
we're not going to be passive
um no we're not going to let
civil power just be you know be be taken
by something that's ordained by God for
people's good to be seized by people who
are you know believe absurd things not
even false things but just utterly
absurd and destructive things I mean it
seems
it's such a pertinent time like God's
Providence and the the timing of this
book coming out especially when you're
talking about a national will and you
have a desire to move people you write
that in the book that you really want to
compel people to take action a Christian
Place uh is something that Christians
have to bring about
and I think what happened is that in
America it was assumed for for uh
decades centuries that we that we are
Christian people we are a Christian
Nation
um and this was just kind of the default
understanding especially in the 18th and
19th centuries
uh and then the neutral World hit that
is this idea where people you know the
secular powers are kind of ambivalent
and let you do what let you do and say
what you want
uh but now we're in the midst of a
negative a negative World whereas
there's there's an act of hostility
towards Christians in order to for civil
institutions for uh
for civil government Civil Society it's
a matter of us saying that's what that's
what this is going to be we're going to
make a Christian government and it's
going to be us willing that into
existence and it's certainly High time
to do it it's high time to take action
you actually Define Christian
nationalism in the book so let me just
read a definition here and we'll talk
about that a little bit Christian
nationalism is a totality of National
Action consisting of civil laws and
social Customs conducted by a Christian
Nation as a Christian Nation in order to
procure for itself both Earthly and
Heavenly good in Christ
people in a Christian Nation would do
that would conduce to their good
um and but I focus in on well how how
are those ordered how do we determine
what those things are
um and that one of them is civil law and
one and the other one is social customs
so civil law is is just something that
the that we're we're basically um
ordered to do by the Magistrate
uh for our good uh and so this
everything from you know
speed limits and I think also Sabbath
laws
and then and we can I mean we can get
into more on that we're going to have to
but you just took people they were with
you with speed limits yes but they lost
you on Sabbath laws yes but we'll come
back I mean we haven't got a teaser and
we got to blasphemy yet um blasphemy
laws
um in uh exercising dominion over the
Earth we are not nor is Adam nor would
Adam have done this we are not bringing
Heavenly life to Earth life we're just
maturing Earthly life according to the
human nature and the principles of the
of this life so how do you order people
how do you order Christians
uh to eternal life well you in an
outward way
you uh you do what you can so that they
can worship God and worship God uh and
uh the the church can administer we're
in sacrament
uh how in particular how would you do
that
you'd have Sabbath laws and Sabbath laws
are not to
simply to punish violations of fourth
Commandment but to provide the but to
provide the conditions in which people
can worship god without distraction
that's the purpose the purpose is not
simply God says fourth Commandment
that's bad so therefore we punish that's
not what what I'm saying
we do that because the fourth
Commandment is is essentially saying
that we ought to worship god corporately
um with with his people
um on a on on Sunday or a special day
and so uh the civil government is there
how are you how can the civil government
in an outward sense
contribute order you to that like like
as I said you they've removed the
distractions of that day so that you can
focus in focus on the worship of God
so Martin there you have the basis of
his thinking
and uh I think he missed something that
what did he say right at the end it's
not part of the video here one of the
main means also that the government can
do it he says is by silencing them so
you silence the the other party the
other party so you have to create these
conditions now Martin this is very
clever strategy
do we in the world have
these kind of theocracies in the Islamic
world yes does the government dictate
the moral milieu of the nation in an
Islamic country yes
now in the Christian countries you've
had the secularism
dictating
and now let's say Europe for example
where these other ideologies are coming
in is there a fear that your way of life
will be destroyed yes yes constantly
constantly in Germany for example this
is a very real situation people are
afraid
that if if it allows to continue in the
way that it is soon you will be subject
to a morality that is foreign to you and
if you have to make a choice now
between that morality
and sticking to your secularism which is
going to be overrun eventually why not
embrace the Christian morality as a
better alternative for you in which to
uh be active yeah
so even even the secularist
if he has a choice between choosing what
he sees happening in Iran for example
and the secular way of life he would
rather opt for Christian nationalism
than to be subject to something which
might be worse right
so it's a very clever game and if if you
see a nation become a Christian Nation
let's say the United States of America
being more and more watered down by all
of these hundreds of ideologies some of
them so liberal that you cannot live
with them and some of them so Draconian
that you cannot live with them why not
opt for Christian nationalism and let's
get back to those roots why
can I ask this question Martin why has
the devil not a long time ago
implemented it because that is what he
had in the Middle Ages because it
wouldn't have worked then why not
because the world was too conservative
and religious still and they still knew
the Antichrist was except when I was
born in fact when I got married and I've
said it many many times people knew who
the Antichrist was protestantism was
protestantism and Catholicism was
Catholicism
the timing is perfect you erode
protestantism
not through a direct frontal attack
through Catholic ideology no through a
backdoor attack of liberalism
infiltrated that one of the champions of
this is studying Thomas Aquinas for
instance yes so here you have this King
of the South ideology which you use
to bring a nation so far that they don't
have any anchor and then you introduce
the Catholic Draconian system that you
had in the Middle Ages but instead of
you doing it you allow protestantism
which has now changed and become like
the Catholics exactly do it for you and
how biblical is that brilliant
everything the false Protestant churches
is under the mother again but doing the
bidding for her
now is is the devilish strategist or not
oh Masters a master strategist so what
looks disjointed
what looks is if he has lost control is
actually absolute meticulous control and
the timing the timing is perfect
absolutely perfect so the mindset if I
just take my lifetime
the mindset how it has changed I mean I
grew up in a Christian nationalist
country yeah how that mindset has
changed into a totally secularized
Nation
I I have experienced it in my lifetime
it's in the last 30 years so now once
it's totally secularized to the point
where even without religion you know
that there's something terribly wrong
morally wrong
people will be prepared to accept this
pendulum swing and go back to the other
system only this time doing the bidding
of the Beast and not the bidding of God
and I must say I think that even
that they will even go to war to bring
about this
there will be a revolution that's what
they said
now Martin if you have a nation like the
United States of America
or a European nation Germany
or England or any one of them where
protestantism prevails
then that Nation will obviously if it
Embraces the Sabbath which he said is
very important to create the climate you
cannot be without the Sabbath
then it'll obviously embrace the Sunday
it he mentioned it and if you live in
that Nation you will knuckle under to
that law because it is a so-called
Christian law even though it's not a
Christian law it's a pagan law but
according to them it is a Christian law
if you live in a Jewish Nation you might
embrace the Sabbath
but in the Christian nations you have to
embrace the Sunday because that is the
law now how do the Jews feel about that
about a Jew living in the United States
for example let's read this this is very
interesting this is the Jewish Insider
book co-authored by gab CEO Andrew tarba
makes Amazon bestseller list and so he's
going to talk about this book now
the Christian nationalist movement has
recently gained a stubborn foothold in
electoral Politics as an increasing
number of Republican candidates across
the country of espoused its doctrines
Andrew tarba one of the co-authors of
Christian nationalism
has worked to build what he describes as
a parallel Christian Society on the
internet
even as his website Gap
has exposed a more Sinister reality our
primary goal is to build a parallel
Christian Society economy and
infrastructure which will fill the
vacuum of the failed secular State when
it fails
are they expecting the secular state to
fail yes the King of the South is going
to be overrun Martin
claiming as a matter of course and
despite evidence to the contrary that
America is a Christian Nation so here we
go God is real the Bible is true Jesus
Christ is King of Kings torban is to
assure themselves declaring that they
are only seeking to reclaim what is
rightfully ours
are unlikely to hear such arguments in
good faith we won't apologize for
anything that we have said or any of the
work we are doing to take Dominion of
our country and culture for the glory of
God they are certain nor should you
they're going to do it and this article
is also accusing him of being an
anti-semitist
it's interesting that I've read articles
in the past where Jewish people say that
America should be a Christian Nation and
that they would be fine with it exactly
we've shown them as well we've shown
those articles
so America's only hope is God says Sean
fart Christian singer activist nation is
morally bankrupt so now here we're at
the right at the end of November 2022
and here at the end of
2022 this ideology is rising like a
mushroom you know what it was building
you remember you first at the what was
those Gatherings that we showed in the
last three years the call and the sen
yes all of this was like a Prelude to
what we've seen now and Jonathan Khan
yes and there you have a Jewish
Christian Rabbi embracing uh
Christian nationalism in the seven month
in Theology and combining
all the aspects of Judaism and
Christianity in a real interesting mix
so
Christian recording artist missionary
and activist Sean foyt will embark on a
50-state kingdom to the Capital Tour
starting in 2023.
I'm looking forward to 2023.
to call on God to come and change
America while encouraging church leaders
to become active in their states on
issues that affect worshipers as a
missionary kid for traveled the world
and witnessed persecution of the church
in many countries he said these feelings
come back after seeing the lockdowns and
governmental overreach casinos and bars
being open and the church being closed
can you see how clever this was
to create the pendulums between the
anger if you take the logic
about the casinos and that being open
the church closed there was no logic but
this was the plan to get this about so
if you neglect the great controversy
issue you will miss all the points isn't
it important
actually next year
the the book of the year is the great
controversy I think it would be good for
every single person to read that book
again everybody should read it
he added then seeing the response of the
church and their unwillingness in many
ways to push back and to just kind of
accept it really alarmed me now why
didn't this even happened within our own
ranks
so this is something that is so
successful and the strategy is so
brilliant that it can deceive the very
elect
exactly and this can you know what
his sentiment yeah can even pull our own
people into this whole debate and they
can be drawn into this Quagmire and end
up in this vortex
I think that covert really helped expose
how much power the state government have
over our lives our communities and over
our churches he said
the pandemic voice said provided an
opportunity for us to react not out of
fear but out of faith so here comes the
pendulum swing backlash
and we're going to go to reclaiming the
seven mountains of power they want to
control business Martin how many people
were fired recently
because of inadequacy or ideology well
we know that with musk it was ideology
that's it so because he was he's
actually cleaning up Twitter yes so cool
why all the others following and why
just after they were at the Vatican
then government they want to control
government they want to reinstate the
family religion on their terms which
happened to be jesuitical terms they
want to control the media the education
and the entertainment who controlled the
education up till now secularism right
yeah
learning against learning wasn't it the
Jesuits who will control the new one
still the same the same people what this
is clever how is that song when will we
ever learn
like we also said nothing new Under the
Sun and entertainment reclaiming the
seven mountains of power and creating
the exact state that the Jews wanted
in the time of Christ and not one stone
was left was left and there will be not
one stone once they have built this
structure either
is an article from the beacon
and it says under reportive and massive
Theocratic movement joins forces with
Michael Flynn and Roger Stone
so now you have the
American Elite even the military leaders
on board
on July 1st
2022 inside the packed Georgia Arena
four religious leaders stood on stage as
they recited a blood chilling prayer
declaration called The Watchman decree
whereas we have been given legal power
from heaven and now exercise The
Authority whereas we are God's
ambassadors and spokespeople over the
Earth whereas through the power of God
We Are the World influencers whereas
because of our covenant with God we are
equipped and delegated by him to destroy
every attempted advance of the enemy we
make our declaration we decree that our
judicial system will issue rulings that
are biblical and constitutional modern
big words right
I wonder whether Heaven is looking at
the little horn power and its pompous
words down here because these words
reflect nothing else than the little
horn
we decree that we take back and
permanently controlled positions of
influence and leadership in each of the
Seven Mountains although few were aware
they had just witnessed the fruits of
the New Apostolic Reformation
the nir we must watch that acronym right
keep New Apostolic authoritarian
movement actually is what it is as we
will see
so the New Apostolic Reformation is
rapidly accelerating and dangerously
under-reported worldwide Christian
authoritarian movement
it practices Faith healing and exorcism
and promotes dominionism
the belief that Christians must take
control of government business and
culture in order for Jesus to return to
the Earth
they're actually quite right they must
take that Dominion so that Jesus will
return and destroy it exactly
and this one is interesting because the
previous one spoke about global movement
right yeah it's
that
rise of the New Apostolic Reformation
it's Global and everywhere they want
Christian countries or actually for that
matter countries to take over the
government or the Seven Mountains again
and we're seeing it all over the world
so if you go and see what's happening in
Italy Melanie's Victory sparked praise
and controversy due to her conservative
values and desire to uphold God family
and country does that fit into the game
perfectly so Europe is climbing on board
right
the others are resisting yeah but the
time for the pendulum to swing well
Sweden has also got a conservative also
the pendulum is swinging
so according to the Christian Post
American news outlets such as the New
York Times have called their a fascist
further CBS News likened her to Italian
fascist dictator Benita Mussolini
she said we will defend God family
country those things that disgust people
so much she said in another speech he
declared yes to the Natural family no to
the LGBT Lobby yes to sexual identity no
to gender ideology does that sound like
pendulum swing completely because you
you hear the complete opposite in the
current
yes to the culture of life no to the
Abbas of death no to the violence of
Islam didn't I mention that just now
yes to safer borders no to mass
immigration yes to work for our people
it's safer to embrace this
than to embrace this unknown threat from
whether it Islam or even this Ultra
liberalism that's it it's a beautiful
strategy now this is like
if you put it on a on a game it's a game
play and Par Excellence you cannot be
actually I don't think humans can think
this up that's why the devil has to sit
behind this it has to be behind it
because it's played on a universal scale
and you wonder sometimes why God allows
it
why does he allow the wicked to flourish
for so long why because his
long-suffering suffering Auntie has to
establish I think that he is truth I
think it's Ecclesiastes eight let me
just check it out and see if I'm right
there
I might be wrong
if you go to Ecclesiastes 8
and you read the well we can actually
read verse 2.
I counsel thee to keep the king's
commandment and that in regard of the
oath of God be not Hasty to go out of
his sight
stand not in an evil thing for we doeth
whatsoever pleases him
now the king that he's referring to of
course typologically is Jesus Christ
so I counseled you to keep the king's
Commandments are these people going to
keep the king's Commandments no they're
going to keep their own but then drop
down to verse 11.
because sentence against the evil work
is not executed speedily
therefore the heart of the sons of men
is fully set in them to do evil
yeah this is the passions of God now but
the interesting thing is once you've
looked at the strategy and you you
realize that it has to be a universal
strategy
the implementation of the biggest is a
universal strategy you have to have so
many things in place and we've been
talking now in this last year
as to how they come into place how you
get Nations that are not Christian to
embrace a Sunday for example
climate
how you get Nations that are highly
secular to embrace Christian laws
Christian nationalism
well this is brilliant and
it's not a plan that has just been
formulated 20 30 years ago this is
coming Millennia so are we to jump onto
this bandwagon no no we're observers
right
so because sentence against an evil work
is not executed speedily therefore the
heart of the sons of men is fully set in
them to do evil though a sinner do evil
a hundred times and his days be
prolonged yet surely I know that it
shall be well with them that fear God
which fear before him so Martin
our job
is to stick to
the Bible
obey God obey the king
and even if it seems that God is
distancing himself and allowing all
these things to happen he's not he's in
control he's in control because he he
said this is going to happen in any case
and if he said it's going to happen and
he said what the conclusion is going to
be that they will be destroyed yeah
then it will happen that's where your
promise lies that's where your focus is
Martin or should be so they can defend
God as much as they like they are not
defending the god of the Bible they are
defending their political structure
it is better that one man die for the
sake of the people that that the people
or the nation should perish for the sake
of one man
same ideology if you oppose this they
have to get rid of you
as the Christian Post also October 2022
Christian nationalism will lead to
Christian persecution SBC president
Barber wants
so Southern Baptist convention president
Baba has condemned the idea that the
church should be running government and
warned Advocates of Christian
nationalism that pursuing such an agenda
will result in persecution of Christians
is he right he's right
is absolutely right yeah so Martin it's
not just us who is saying this there are
people that are seeing the danger and
warning against this danger but in spite
of it
they will go ahead you see he's in the
minority he is one of those people that
the spirit of Prophecy is talking about
that will join the loud cry movement at
the end you're absolutely right it
stands contrary to 400 years of Baptist
history and everything I believe about
religious liberty I'm opposed to the
idea of Christian Dominion churchly
dominion over the operations of
government Baba insisted in a
wide-ranging interview with Anderson
Cooper on CBS 60 Minutes on Sunday
button this is the stand that we should
have this is what we should have exactly
I object to it because Jesus said his
kingdom is not of this world there are
people that understand I object to it
because every time it's been adopted it
wound up persecuting people like me it
doesn't stop at persecuting people who
are not Christians he said it eventually
winds up persecuting people who are
Christians from whom the flavor of their
Christianity is different from that of
the government Martin
we are there yes and if we don't open
our eyes we will be sucked into this
vortex
our people our church
are supposed to be speaking like this
guy we should be waking up
let's end with a lengthy quote from the
spirit of Prophecy
The Peculiar work of the third Angel has
not been seen in its importance
God meant that his people should be far
in advance of the position they occupied
today Martin I can conquer with that
but now when the time has come for them
to spring into action they have the
preparation to make when the national
reformers began to urge measures to
restrict religious liberty our Leading
Men should have been alive to the
situation and should have labored
earnestly to counteract their efforts I
don't want to say anything about the
last two years
because I wish they had done that
exactly
it is not in the order of God that light
has been kept from our people the very
present truth which they needed for this
time not all our ministers who are
giving the third Angel's message really
understand what constitutes that message
the national Reform movement has been
regarded by some of so little importance
that they have not thought it necessary
to give much attention to it and have
even felt that in so doing that would be
giving time to the question distinct
from the third Angel's message
may the Lord forgive our brethren for
thus interpreting the very message for
this time
the people need to be aroused in regard
to the dangers of the present time the
Watchmen are asleep we are years behind
let the chief Watchmen feel the Urgent
necessity of taking heed to themselves
unless they lose the opportunity given
them to see the dangers
if the leading men in our conferences do
not now accept the message sent them by
God and fall into line for Action the
churches will suffer great loss
these words are more important now yes
than they were when she wrote them it's
100 percent
when the Watchman seeing the sword
coming gives the trumpet a certain sound
the people along the line will Echo the
warning and all will have opportunity to
make ready for the conflict
Martin
should a Baptist give the warning and
not us
but too often the leader has stood
hesitating seeming to say let us not be
into great haste there may be a mistake
we must be careful not to raise a false
alarm the very hesitancy and uncertainty
on this part is crying peace and safety
the time is not yet hmm
do not get excited
be not alarmed there's a great deal more
made of this religious Amendment
question than is demanded this agitation
will all die down thus he virtually
denies the message sent from God and the
warning which was designed to stir the
churches fails to do its work
The Trumpet of the Watchman gives no
certain sound and the people do not
prepare for the battle
Let The Watchmen beware lest through his
hesitancy And Delay Souls shall be left
to perish and their blood shall be
required at their hand we have been
looking for many years for a Sunday law
to be enacted in our land and now that
the movement is Right upon us
Martin is she writing for her time of
hours
it was for then the type but we are that
the anti-type thank you
will our people do their holy Duty in
the matter can we not assist in lifting
the standard and in calling to the front
those who have a regard for their
religious rights and privileges
the time is fast approaching when those
who choose to obey God rather than man
will be made to feel the hand of the
oppression
shall we then dishonor God by keeping
silent while his holy Commandments are
trodden underfoot
if you trust the king then keep his
Commandments
and God will act even if it seems to
Tarry
and didn't that Baptist
preacher tell us that
Christians will not be spared
persecution if you don't align yourself
with their ideology for certain
button
here at the close of this year 2022.
I am looking forward to 2023
to see how this unfolds
and then to see how in 2024 when
governments change again in the United
States
things might be very different to what
they are today the last events will be
rapid ones rapid ones may God give us
wisdom and may he give God's people
wisdom to discern the times we are
living in let's pray amen
Heavenly Father
things are unfolding before our eyes we
have spoken many times about pendulum
swing
and we see the pendulum swinging
unfortunately it is swinging
in the direction of an ideology which is
not based on the Bible
but on an opinion of dominionism
may God grant us wisdom to discern
right from wrong is my prayer in Jesus
name amen amen
[Music]
thank you